we've got a very special treat for you
guys today we've got safety who's going
to join us
uh most of you know him as the author of
the bitcoin standard probably the best
book
uh in terms of helping understand uh
where we are headed
uh let's bring him up here real quick
safety how are you
i'm very good thank you for having me no
thank you for doing this
um let's just jump right into it you've
got a new book coming out
uh which is a play on words from the
last title uh the fiat standard tell us
kind of one why are you writing a second
book i feel like that's not an easy task
and then two what uh what's the book
about
well the short answer for why i write
the book is that the first one seemed to
work and so you know you follow market
signals people like the first one you
give them more of what they like
and it is a play on the title but it's
also more than just a play on the title
it's kind of like a play on the whole
book
in that i take the uh way in which i
studied and approached
uh the bitcoin standard in which i
studied the bitcoin and i apply it
to fiat you know um so think about if
you were trying to
explain fiat as if it was a digital
currency
how would you explain it what would the
white paper look like uh
what's the dev team uh who runs a node
how can you run a node
if you think about fiat in these terms i
think because bitcoin is such an
advanced
form of money and it was designed by a
very brilliant engineer and it's been
worked on by a lot of brilliant
engineers since then
i think it's a great example of
everything that you need in order to
make a monetary system function
and so then you can look at fiat through
that lens
and you'll get a lot of clarity about
how fiat actually functions
so that was the motivation for writing
this book as i started to think about
fiat as
another digital currency and i'm trying
to explain and understand
uh what it is doing and how it functions
it actually i found
i found it to be very useful uh as a way
of
understanding the fiat system and so
when you start thinking about the
fiat system most people think of it as
two completely
diametrically opposed systems right one
is transparent decentralized
open source uh programmatic et cetera
and the other is
basically the exact opposite is that
your general read on the two systems or
do you have some sort of
uh kind of more nuance to the comparison
um there's there's a lot to the
comparison so i think the
perhaps the most uh powerful tool is
when you try and think about how mining
works in fiat
so in bitcoin we know that you know the
miners solve the proof of work problems
and then they get issued new coins and
there's a schedule for how many coins
they get
in gold we know that you mine gold by
digging into the ground and then
refining it
but in fiat if you ask yourself how is
fiat mined
it's a very deep rabbit hole and when
you start thinking about it and start
thinking about the significance
in terms of you know just think about
how much of a big deal mining bitcoin is
and then you transport you you you apply
that to fiat and you can see
why uh lending is such a big deal
because the way that
mining fiat works is through lending
when you go to the bank
and you ask them for a million dollars
so you can buy a house the bank
isn't taking one million dollars that
somebody else had deposited in that bank
and giving them to you
the bank is making mining essentially
new fiat so
if they can get you to borrow they get
to make new fiat money that's the
equivalent of solving a proof of work
problem
it's finding a lender finding a borrower
who wants to borrow
and who fulfills the criteria for
borrowing
and then being able to issue the loan
that allows them to make more money
when you think about it this way the
fiat system begins to make a lot of
sense
so that's why everybody's in debt that's
why
in fiat you know no matter how much
money you get you just keep
rolling it over into bigger and bigger
debt people don't make money so they can
pay off their debts people make money so
they can take on
bigger debts so individuals are in debt
corporations are in debt
governments are in debt at all levels
municipal and national and everything
everybody needs to get in debt because
when you get in debt you know if you
wanted to buy the house
uh with cash if you just had a house and
you wanted to buy it with cash well
that's to say a million dollar house
but if you're able to get it uh with a
mortgage
then the bank is going to effectively
make eight hundred thousand dollars out
of thin air
you'll put up say twenty thousand two
hundred thousand uh up front
but then the bank managed to make eight
hundred thousand so they can cut you a
sweet deal here because
it's not like you're uh taking up uh you
know it's not like you're taking up
their capital they just get to make
new capital so if buying a house can be
used as a way to mine
fiat it's going to be very profitable
for the miner and they'll cut you in on
that and that's why it makes sense for
everybody to
buy their houses in that everybody buys
their houses and their major expenses
you get into debt and you get a better
deal than if you pay cash
because obviously you know over time the
value of the money declines
and the value of the repayment of the
loan continues to decline
so when you think about uh let's talk
nation state debt versus
individual debt and corporate debt
there's different
players in the market that are all
taking on debt is it fair to say it's
all the exact same
structure so the government takes on
debt because they're going to be able to
pay it off with cheaper dollars in the
future
same as the individual buying that house
or some other good um
is that kind of a fair way to categorize
in your opinion
um i mean it's not exactly the same
because uh depends on your credit
worthiness and it depends on
your political connections and so the
issue here of course is that
this isn't uh this isn't an advanced and
fair system like bitcoin where
anybody can solve the proof of work
problems and get rewarded
and the only way to guarantee that you
can make more uh solutions for the proof
of work
is to mine more efficiently and
have more miners and have more
electricity well in fiat it doesn't
quite work that way in order to mine
fiat
basically you need to be well connected
to the federal reserve to the government
to the central bank in whatever country
you're in and the way it works is
government obviously gets to borrow at
the lowest rate because government has
the advantage of being able to
um tax and inflate the currency
to pay off the debt so therefore you'll
see that they get to borrow at the
lowest rate everywhere
and then everybody else's um
interest rate will be a little bit
higher so effectively you know
you people are mostly probably familiar
with the term the cantion effect and the
canteen effect refers to the fact that
when you
print new money the recipients of the
new money
benefit at the expense of the people who
were holding the old money
and the people who receive it earlier
benefit the most
and then as the money trickles through
the rest of the economy
the benefits decline and then the people
who receive it
later um don't even benefit from it they
are hurt from the inflation that it
causes
so in the case of fiat the way the
canteen effect is essentially
the way that the cantian effect works is
essentially through
interest rate um people who get lowest
interest rates
on their debt benefit and so that's
government
and the biggest borrowers in society
which are
primarily the biggest the biggest
financial institutions in banks
and then the bigger corporations that
can borrow from
the banks at the lowest interest rates
but then as you move forward
as you move towards you know the hoi
polloi and the peasants
the interest rates go up and you are
effectively
missing out on the benefits of this
you're not being able to catch up with
inflation if you think about
inflation in terms of cpi then
you could get the impression that a lot
of people are able to keep up with
inflation but of course
that's entirely dependent on the kind of
goods that you include in the cpi and
that does not include
the desirable goods that are highly
competitive because they're rare you
know you can't have
um miami beach real estate and
manhattan real estate in the cpi because
that's
always going up much faster than cpi and
the best healthcare the best medicine
the best all of the things that are very
scarce by their nature because they're
very high quality
all these things are rising at a much
faster pace than the cpi
and so the only people who can keep up
are the ones who are the
best connected so essentially government
and the big banks and
the people who are you know the people
who run these things
so we spent the first half of the show
talking about what i call inflate gate
which is just the uh controversy around
inflation and what the real numbers are
do you have an opinion in terms of how
off the official numbers are
uh or maybe you believe that the
official numbers are correct no i think
they're uh definitely off but i'm i'm
definitely with michael saylor
on i think marcus sailer is absolutely
brilliant in the way that he explains
inflation as being
a vector rather than a scalar quantity
so
you can't just summarize inflation with
one number you can't say that
um you know the economy's average basket
of goods has gone up by three percent
this year or five percent
it doesn't mean anything because that's
entirely dependent on what you include
in the basket of goods
and so you're essentially just measuring
what you've included
but i think a more relevant metric is to
look at goods individually and you see
the rise in the individual prices of
goods then you can see that then you can
portray
inflation as a vector where each
each good has its own inflation rate and
so in that respect
you'll see that inflation is very high
in
prime real estate as i was mentioning is
very high in luxury goods it's very
high in good education
good credentialed education all of these
things continue to rise at much higher
rates than the cpi
what is rising at this rate of the cpi
on the main things that are included in
the cpi
are essentially things that are low
quality that are available
because that don't rise that are not
very responsive to inflation because
they can be produced at a large scale
very quickly in response to
increases in demand and so the best
example in my mind is like junk food
there are very little limits on how much
more junk food you can do there are a
lot of factories out there
that can just churn out very large
quantities of junk food and so if
there's
an increase in inflation they can
increase the production
and the price won't go up by much um
same i think is true of cheap goods you
know
mass-produced cheap goods these things
if you look at them you know you'll see
that the
rise in their price is probably are
similar to what
you get in the cpi one two three four
percent per year per year
um digital goods on the other hand they
get cheaper every year so
their inflation rate is negative you
know if you look at the cost of
disk space or the cost of using
google or using youtube you know the
all these technological things keep
getting better and
they keep getting cheaper over time but
that's just technology that's advancing
but i think the real inflation shows up
in the scarce goods and i think another
brilliant insight from michael saylor is
you see it in
bonds you see it in how much do you have
to buy
what is the size of the bond that you
need to buy in order to be able to
afford retirement and so if you're
thinking of retiring and you want let's
say 20 years of income
how much do you need to buy how much
bonds do you need to buy
for 20 years of retirement and
given the collapsing yield of bonds the
price that you need to spend on these
things
is enormous and so that's going up much
faster than the cpi
so quibbling over the little numbers of
you know is it
two or two point five or three or three
point five or five or whatever
uh is i think kind of missing the big
picture in the big picture is that
uh for the things that matter for the
things that people actually want
for the things that can secure their
future you know a house in a good
neighborhood
uh a good education for your children
a house in a neighborhood that has a
good school
retirement all of these things they're
just getting expensive
at a much faster rate than the cpi at a
rate at a rate that
closely approximate the inc approximates
the increase
in m2 in the money supply when you think
about
um what to do is it
just go by bitcoin is it by real estate
is it by
gold other types of commodities um you
know i think you and i are both
sympathetic to the view of the world
that like inflation is
uh much higher um there's unlikely to be
anything kind of stopping this from
continuing just given the
macro structure um and kind of uh we
talked earlier about like
the people who are in charge have no
choice they know that they have to solve
short-term problems at the expense of
long-term damage
because that is what the incentive
system drives so it's not them
individually their fault
it's just kind of the the system that
they're in but what does the individual
do in your opinion
so i guess the moral of the bitcoin
standard you know the lesson of the
bitcoin standard was that bitcoin's
number goes up
and therefore buy bitcoin i think the uh
the lesson of the fiat standard is
fiat's number
go down fiat is number go down
technology and the best way to protect
yourself from that
is to short fiat and to borrow fiat
and i think um it it it's given me a lot
of appreciation and
and i say this as somebody who used to
think that debt is just a bad thing and
i don't want to get into debt and i want
to just have savings and
this is why bitcoin was such a great
find for me because it was a form of
saving that worked because before that
you could use gold and gold was
uh not very good you know it's been
basically flat over the last 10 years
so when i found bitcoin it was very good
because it's a form of saving that you
can
uh use but now i truly understand that
under a fiat system if you're not
getting in debt you're essentially
subsidizing everybody else for getting
into debt
and so if you're the sucker who buys
their house in cash
you're overpaying for the house and
you're subsidizing everybody else who's
buying their house
on a mortgage now of course that doesn't
mean everybody should go out
and max all their credit cards and get
all the debt that they can
um you know the the flip side of this is
that it's not like holding bitcoin you
know holding negative fiat balances is a
highly stressful thing
it means you have payments to make and
you need to be able to make sure that
your cash flows
can cover all of your payments because
if they don't you could lose your
collateral you could get kicked out of
your house or whatever it is
so uh it's a risky business but
basically this is
um i think this is the lesson of the
fiat standard that it puts
everybody on a treadmill where you need
to
be constantly highly stressed and making
payments and
close to insolvency and highly
vulnerable to any kind of
shock that can affect your business
because
you can't have savings and you need to
have
uh you need to have debt and so
everybody's more fragile
and it's um in a sense it's like walking
in a
field of landmines you never know when
something might happen
and your business uh misses a couple of
payments and then your business is gone
so you know you have to be very careful
with it but i think i
i see the case for getting into debt in
fiat and i think
you know i used to live in lebanon and i
saw the implosion
of the lebanese economy and you know
it's been absolutely terrible for people
who had savings in the banks
and it's terrible for people who lost
their jobs but there's one group of
people that
made out fine out of it which is people
who had lebanese lira denominated debt
so i have friends who
are essentially uh paying off the
remaining
of you know the next 20 years of their
mortgage they're going to be paying off
something like 10 or 5 percent of their
original payment because their payments
were denominated in the lira
so this is really the way to protect
yourself against
uh fiat and if you listen to what
michael saylor says you know he says
you should not sell your bitcoin ever
you do what rich people do
and apparently this has been something
that rich people have known for quite a
while and i've only just discovered it
now
which tells you a lot i guess uh but
this is how rich people do it you know
this is what also robert kiyosaki
talks about you know you want to get
into as much debt as possible
at as low a rate as possible as long as
you're sure that you can cover payments
and then you don't have to sell anything
you keep accumulating hard assets that's
the way to do it accumulate hard assets
and get into debt in fiat that's the
cheat code basically you want all your
assets to be
hard or bitcoin ideally and you want
your debt to be
uh fiat yeah what you're basically
describing is the whole idea of you know
especially in america parents always
telling people like go get real estate
everyone makes money in real estate and
really the entire secret to real estate
is you're
borrowing money uh to buy an asset and
then if you're renting it out using
somebody else's money to make the
payments and therefore
maybe you have a down payment or you
know kind of one time payment or some
small percentage
but you're essentially using financial
engineering and this mechanism to end up
owning the hard asset
but it's either borrowed money or
somebody else's money and then you
end up with the asset at the end like
that has been a time tested strategy for
you know literally decades if not
centuries um now it's just
as people start to understand it from a
currency perspective in the fiat world
and also see something like bitcoin
michael saylor is executing uh you know
what i think most people would have
referred to as like the speculative
attack
uh you know converting that fiat in into
a hard asset
but really it's no different than if he
was borrowing money to buy real estate
he was a real estate business
right it's almost identical to you know
a very similar thing
yeah and the difference of course and
that's kind of the um
the conclusion of the book is that
bitcoin is
real estate on steroids you know real
estate does 5 10
15 a year or something like that
bitcoin's been averaging 200
a year over the last 10 years and this
year you know bitcoin only needs to end
the year at 51
000 in order to continue the 200 annual
uh growth rate on average over the last
11 years
so if this trend continues you know
it's uh i think that's going to be the
most interesting question in the future
which is
how do we deal with what happens when
fiat is inflating because everybody's
borrowing fiat because they're
buying bitcoin and so people are
accumulating bitcoin
by borrowing fiat it's um i think
one kind of um perhaps sad
uh conclusion from it is that the people
who have fiat privilege are gonna
transfer their fiat privilege into
bitcoin privilege by
borrowing uh large amounts of fiat at
low interest rates and
using it to buy a lot of bitcoin um i
think another potential possibility is
that we might get some kind of
government restriction on the ability of
people to borrow and buy bitcoin
so they may not clamp down on bitcoin or
make bitcoin criminalized
but they might make it so that if you
have bitcoin you don't get to borrow you
don't get
access to capital markets i think
we could perhaps see something like this
at some point but i think
uh because you know otherwise it's just
you can't really see how else this would
go
you know people are just going to see
more and more michael sailors bring up
and they're going to all want to do it
and everybody's going to max out their
mortgage
and their credit card and everything
that they can do so that they
are in as big a fiat debt as possible so
that they can stack as much stats as
possible
you know that just means much more
dollar inflation and much more
um bitcoin number go up uh
uh so it'll be very interesting to watch
how this unfolds over the next
few decades so you're pretty convinced
that they're going to stop people from
borrowing to
be able to buy no i don't think so i
mean i'm i i'm
agnostic about the possibility i don't
know what the probability is but i think
this is one kind of attack vector yeah
it's an option and i think it's one way
they could attack bitcoin i think
we're probably past the stage where they
could just criminalize it like drugs and
go after people
door-to-door to check if they have
bitcoin um
but this is perhaps one way in which the
empire can fight back
yeah when you start to think about um
kind of the fiat system
what do you expect uh the conclusion
here
is there like a showdown the final boss
you know that type of a thought process
or are you more sympathetic to the idea
that uh
over time we'll get more cynthia
lummus's uh in the senate or warren
davidson's in congress they'll kind of
get educated they'll realize hey look
you know this is actually a pretty good
transparent system and and they'll
become proponents and advocates and
over time you just need more and more of
those people in positions of power and
influence and they kind of
start the the slow adoption like is it
more
confrontational or is it more kind of
over time you just slowly get people
uh familiar and educated with the asset
and with the system and that leads to
the ultimate adoption
i think the uh you know in the book i
discuss both both possibilities and
um you know i don't have a crystal ball
to be able to tell which one's going to
happen but i'll say
up until covet hit i was leaning much
more toward the fact that
this is just going to be and that was
kind of the conclusion of the book that
i was getting at when i first started
writing the book which is
bitcoin is the peaceful monetary upgrade
it's like you got a smart software
engineer into your house
and he took out your old clunky windows
x7 or whatever it is that has been
messing up everything in your life
and he just uninstalled it and gave you
a brand new operating system
that works in a sense you could think of
bitcoin as being like that
and i could see i could make the case
for
um for why bitcoin allows us to unravel
fiat
relatively peacefully because people
generally think all right well bitcoin
can bitcoin will lead to uh people
dropping demand for the dollar and then
people not
holding as much dollar and so if demand
for the dollar drops
then the price of the dollar drops and
then we get hyperinflation but that's
not exactly how hyperinflation happens
hyperinflation usually happens because
of an increase in the supply you know if
you look at places where the currency
collapses
it has always been it has always
coincided with massive
money printing there's always a point in
the money supply where it
does the hockey stick and then the value
of the currency starts crashing
so you never get hyper inflation because
demand declines you know if the currency
drops 95
that's not because people in the country
had dropped their demand for the
currency by 95 percent
it's because the uh quantity of the
money supply has gone up
tenfold or something like that so um
in that sense i think people might be
missing one thing which bitcoin does
which is
potentially while yes it might lead to
more and more
uh debt creation but there is a case to
be made that
it might actually lead for the uh to the
opposite which is
that um people start stacking
um start holding bitcoin
instead of holding debt assets so at the
end of the day
in order for you to borrow you need
somebody to lend and
um usually you know if you think about
why there's such a
huge supply of loans out there is
because people want to hold
debt as an asset on their balance sheet
and particularly
bonds and so if you run a company you
have your cash
balance or your treasury reserve usually
you have some
cash but you usually have a lot of bonds
that's what people use bonds for because
it doesn't have equity risk
and it's senior to equity in terms of
if there is a bankruptcy
so it's a more safe asset to keep on
your treasury
but if people start realizing you know
what we don't want to hold bonds we
don't want to be lenders
and we'd rather just hold bitcoin if and
that's kind of the
the other side of the michael saylor
strategy which is all right he's
borrowing himself
but um he's not holding treasuries
anymore
and so there might come a point in which
uh you know the demand
the supply for people like michael
sailor to borrow
declines because everybody's doing a
michael sailor by stacking
bitcoin rather than holding bonds and so
so we get a decline in the demand for
the dollar because people are not
holding dollars and they're holding more
uh bitcoin but we also get a decline in
the supply of the dollars
because people are not borrowing as much
people are not
issuing as much loans because they're
just holding on to bitcoin
and so that way we can kind of make the
fiat house of cards unravel peacefully
where you could think
you know you can take out take apart a
house of cards
if you take one card supporting the
other you remove the two of them at the
same
time you do it at each level and then
you could unravel the house of cards
neatly and put it back in the
um in the in the card box
uh and that might be what bitcoin does
it increases demand for bitcoin
decreases demand for holding dollars
and decreases the supply of new dollars
that are created
and so what happens is that the price of
bitcoin goes up the bitcoin-based
economy goes up
and the fiat-based economy starts
shrinking in size relative to the
bitcoin
based economy until it's essentially
shrinks into nothingness
and there is a case to be made i think
for the fact that this can unravel
peacefully because when you get
hyperinflation
the reason you get hyperinflation is
that at any country in which there's
hyperinflation it's not just
that the currency is being destroyed by
the central bank
it's also that the currency is being
destroyed
and people have no alternative so people
in lebanon
can't just switch to the dollar they
can't just have an entire financial
system that operates based around the
dollar
and you know just get rid of their
leaders buy dollars and start over again
and start
doing all of their accounting in dollars
that's not possible you don't have
dollar banks in lebanon
but with bitcoin and you know still
admittedly bitcoin is still a little too
early to help a place like lebanon
because you don't have the
infrastructure but in five years ten
years time
as inflation becomes a bigger problem
you
have a ready-made alternative and so
inflation doesn't have to be
catastrophic in the long run
among the more advanced economies that
are probably going to be a few more
years before they experience
a very bad inflation outcome
and at that point bitcoin is just a
ready-made
lifeboat lifeboat slash space rocket
where you know once it finally dawns
upon you that
um this fiat boat that i'm on
is not doing very well you just upgrade
you move to bitcoin you start getting
paid in bitcoin you start making your
payments in bitcoin
and more and more people do this and
then you know maybe the transition you
know use people's
lose some money in the transition but as
long as you're able to upgrade to an
operational system that is uh functional
then
maybe that doesn't have to be
catastrophic but i think
you know since i started writing the
book with the coronavirus
hysteria that has happened and the
insane way in which governments have
responded
both in terms of their monetary policies
as well as their
[Music]
public health policies i think
we may be in for a rougher landing
because
uh uh you know they're printing so much
the money printer is going
bur very fast that uh who knows what's
going to happen you know we may be
witnessing very fast inflation
before uh bitcoin is large enough to
support
a very large number of people before
people can make this transition so
we might not be able to unravel that
house of cards very uh smoothly
joe john what questions you guys have
yeah i can go first uh thanks for doing
this i appreciate it i was looking at uh
kind of some of the information on the
book website and i got a laugh out of
michael saylor's recommendation that he
uh he said the best recommendation or
the best compliment i can give is that i
read this book and then bought 425
million dollars of bitcoin
which i thought was probably the best
compliment you could get so that's
awesome
but my question is kind of uh was kind
of answered i guess a little bit
previously but i want to see if you can
kind of go a little deeper on it which
is
about 20 of uh american adults currently
own bitcoin here in the united states
so i'm curious like how do we get to 40
how do we get to 60
how do we go higher is it strictly
education is it uh
regulatory changes is it adoption by
public facing figures maybe politicians
etc
just how do you think about that first
of all i really doubt it's 20
i think i saw a gallup poll that said
six percent
uh and i think um
that's probably more realistic but yeah
um
in my mind i think the way that bitcoin
gains in adoption is
through number go up technology it's
the best advertisement it's the value
proposition
and i think the more uh
bad monetary policy is the better of an
advertisement it is for bitcoin and i
think
this really is the um this really is the
best advertisement i think you know all
the work that we're doing on twitter
um meaning and posting all day is great
i salute the effort of all the uh
meme warriors out there but i think
realistically
um you know the most powerful meme is
the fact that the price goes up
the most powerful meme is that you hear
about bitcoin and you hear about a price
and then you hear about a crash and then
you close and he's like ahaha it was at
1 000 and now it's at 200 hahaha what a
stupid joke
and the next time you hear about it it's
at 25 000 and then it smacks you in the
face and then you start paying attention
i think that's ultimately i mean you
can't buy that kind of marketing
there's just nothing like it uh it's
it's why i call it you know the unique
and proprietary number go up technology
nobody
can copy this i think that's really what
it's going to take and i think um
another one of powerful advertisement
for bitcoin i think is going to be
central bank digital currencies
because it's um it's such an enormous
concession of frame
by the central bank it's amazing like
they've just gone oh yeah
you guys have better technology but it's
fine because we're going to make it
better than you so they've just
basically admitted that our technology
is better than theirs
and that's just forcing a lot of people
to start think more about bitcoin and i
think when they
roll out these central bank digital
currencies which are going to be
you know essentially bringing the uh
soviet goss bank
model in the people's bank the central
bank of the soviet union
in which everybody in the country had an
account with the central bank and it was
one central bank that
uh i mean it was literally a central
bank there was just one bank and
everybody had an account with it and it
controlled all aspects of your life um
if we have
that i think you know you can imagine
just how much
politically that's going to be abused by
the um people in power
who are going to use it to impose all
kinds of ideological positions that they
have so
you can say goodbye to buying meat or
buying fuel
with your central bank digital currency
because we all know that
you know meat is boiling the oceans and
uh
your car is causing the um
himalayas to melt and the oceans to
acidify and you're killing all the fish
so you're going to be banned from doing
that and people who want to stay warm in
the winter
and people who like to eat meat are
going to have to start looking into
serious
alternatives and that's you know
if if the number go up misses them then
i think the central bank digital
currencies
are going to get us all the rest
i like that john what you got yeah
thanks for doing this uh congratulations
on your new book i know that's not an
easy feat
i never wrote one myself so i'm excited
too uh excited to read it
but i'm curious if you could elaborate
kind of what you think about debt
um versus bitcoin you talked about some
people even taking it out right what you
think about in your like personal
portfolio and then
what people should think about it i know
everyone's situation is a little bit
different but um
i hope you can talk about that a little
bit yeah i mean
honestly i i hesitate to give financial
advice because i'm just not very good at
that stuff
i'm not a finance person i an academic
who
reads old old books and
tries and to get the insights from those
books and apply them to
modern things and i'm very hesitant to
give people advice
um i'll say like you know the case for
stacking sats as much as you can is
indisputable and you just hold bitcoin
for four years at least and there's no
way that you're going to be down
i was just running some numbers today
there's never been a day in which
bitcoin was down
on a four-year timeline the lowest it
has ever been at four years was
4.2 multiple on a four-year basis
and the average has been something like
300 x the average over the last five
years is around 20 x
so basically if you hold bitcoin for
four years you're gonna get a 20x or so
and if you're stacking you're roughly
you know if you're
periodically stacking you're going to be
doing a 20x over four years which i
think is
phenomenal and you know um it's
kind of ridiculous to be trying to beat
that and to maximize on it
but you know people always try
ridiculous things
i think there is a good case perhaps to
be made for
getting into some debt in order to stack
more bitcoin
as long as you know for sure that you
have um good cash
flow that can cover it and that you have
good collateral so you wouldn't want to
take on large amounts of debt that
could get you liquidated but i think you
know perhaps a small amount
um you know and for most people this is
likely
to be best achieved through getting a
mortgage um
if you if you're considering buying a
house a cash out right versus
buying it via mortgage i think
you'll be able to probably stack more
sats if you
well almost definitely you'll have more
satoshis if you
are borrowing to buy the house rather
than paying in cash
i think so there probably is a case for
integrating debt into
into your portfolio more than just
stacking stats and i think
because ultimately if you're not doing
that you're effectively subsidizing
people who are doing it like you're
forced to play this game because there's
only one currency and there's a monopoly
central bank
and it's enforcing its interest rates
and you have to play that game so
uh you either play it by subsidizing
others or
you take advantage of it yourself and
you try and get yourself a piece of the
pie
safety when you start to think about
kind of the milestones moving forward
are there specific things that you're
looking for
to signal either adoption uh cracks in
the armor
of the existing system uh or potentially
that uh that harmonious
uh transition as more and more people
start to uh to understand bitcoin or is
there anything that kind of sticks out
in your mind as
these will be kind of milestones maybe a
public company buying bitcoin putting on
their balance sheet was one of those
but are there any others that you look
at yeah i think public companies is a
big one i think perhaps the next
big the next big milestone ahead of us
might just be the point at which bitcoin
becomes bigger than
u.s treasuries at this point the us debt
is around 29 trillion dollars and
bitcoin is around
uh 800 billion dollars so there's still
about a 30
40 fold and difference so bitcoin is
only about 2.5
of the uh
of the treasury uh of the u.s treasuries
and i think this is significant because
when people are going to be thinking
about treasury reserve assets that they
want to use
they're always thinking about what is
the most liquid asset and
the us treasuries are um you know the
liquid
the treasury asset of choice because
they're the most liquid it's a 30
trillion dollar
liquid market and if you have some
treasuries
you're not gonna be uh in a lot of
trouble trying to sell them
relatively and at least that's how it's
worked over the past
50 60 years of fiat but
i think the moment when bitcoin becomes
bigger than the treasury market
and of course and realistically bitcoin
doesn't even need to become bigger than
the entire treasury market because the
entire treasury market has
a lot of different maturities so it's
not exactly like you're buying one
uh good like one u.s treasury bond
is not equal to one u.s treasury bond
one of them has a five-year maturity
that was issued yesterday
the other one has a 15-year maturity
that was issued 10 years ago
so that they're different in um
and they all have different markets at
which they're trading so
uh bitcoin is just one asset so one
satoshi is one satoshi so
it's already bigger than big chunks of
the us treasury market
but when it starts becoming comparable
and when you know when it's at
10 15 trillion dollars and treasury
market is at
30 i think a lot of people are going to
pay attention to it because at that
scale
you can get more liquidity
by liquidating your bitcoin uh you know
you can
you can sell your bitcoin and expect
less slippage with your bitcoin
than you would with treasury bonds and i
think that's going to be a major turning
point
at that point you know if bitcoin has
been around for 15 20 years or so
and it has a liquidity that is close or
comparable
to the size of the us treasury market at
that point
it's going to be very hard for cfas
across the world
to justify not taking a position in
bitcoin
at that point it's going to really just
be the bitter dead ender
no coiners that are you know stuck
out in um in in fiat land and refusing
to deal with it but
the vast majority of pragmatic people
are just going to recognize this is a
much better asset and i think
might be a major tipping point it might
really be a major tipping point
i uh i tend to agree with you uh which i
think my brothers do as well
uh before we let you go where can we
send people uh one obviously to follow
you on
twitter but also to uh buy the new book
the fiat standard
yeah you can pre-order it right now and
read it you'll get the
full draft of the book it's uh being
sent to the printers soon the book will
be out in december but you can read it
right now
if you pre-order it you can pre-order
the digital copy or the
uh audio copy or the physical copy and
you can also
support my self-publication effort by
buying a signed copy
and getting your name listed as a
supporter in
the book and you can do that on my
website safetydean.com
and for that page in particular just go
to slash tfs safety.com
tfs for the fiat standard so there you
can pre-order the book and you'll get
the digital copy today and you'll be
able to read it it's not entirely final
but it's very close to final
awesome well i highly suggest people go
check it out first if you ever read the
bitcoin standard i suggest that if you
uh haven't yet pre-ordered the fiat
standard definitely suggest you do that
as well
thank you so much for uh for taking the
time to do this i literally could talk
to you for hours
uh i feel like you just got a great uh
great grasp of what's happening in the
world and kind of where we're going so
please keep it up
and uh we'll do this again soon awesome
thank you so much for having me guys
have a good day thanks sounds good